I know what you're all doing here for
eight seasons we got to follow this
iconic crew of Wisconsin kids as they
navigated love life and red Foreman's
attitude even though the show ran for
200 episodes it only covered about 3
years of time so I decided to do a
little imagining of my own with AI
generated characters that' 7s show meet
that 60s show Eric Foreman the most
protagonist character we have out of
That 70s Ensemble was 16 or 7 in the
first season of the show and he was
around 21 when the series ended toe for
Grace was 20 when he first started
playing Eric in 27 when the show ended
the show Mostly centered around Eric and
his relationship with his friends as
they often gathered at his house more
specifically in his basement we also got
to see some major focus on Eric's
parents red and kitty who often had
major story lines that intertwined with
the' 70s kids needless to say the show
wouldn't have been the same without Eric
Foreman front and center with this
reimagined AI generated art of him as a
child he still looks like the kid who
would invite everybody over and would
continue to get more witty and sarcastic
as he grows up we all know Donna as
Eric's ongoing love interest throughout
the series and according to That 70s
Show lore they've been best friends
since childhood honestly it would be so
cute to have a prequel to see how they
interacted in grade school Donna was
around 17 at the beginning of the series
and around 21 at the end Laura Prepon
was 18 when she first stepped into
Donna's shoes and 26 when the show ended
this AI generated art shows Donna's
signature red hair and bright blue eyes
unmistakable Donna pinchotti Donna has
always been stubborn strong and has
always notoriously beaten Eric at pretty
much every competitive game they've ever
played so I'm sure she'd be courageous
protecting Eric from every school bully
to cross his path oh sweet dumb Kelso
I'd love to know what your childhood was
like Ashton Kutcher really played his
hmbo comic relief and toxic boyfriend
character to utter Perfection his
character is most notably known for his
on again off again relationship with
Jackie and was constantly looking for
ways to cut Corners in their
relationship spoiler alert he actually
ended up having an affair with Eric's
older sister Lori Kelso was actually
believed to be a little bit older than
the rest of the group around 18 but you
really couldn't tell by his mannerisms
Ashton Kutcher was around 20 when he
first started playing Kelo and around 28
when the series ended looking at this
adorable AI generated image I can still
kind of hear him yelling Jackie on the
playground okay KN going to lie fez's
character in the show was highly
problematic but let's reimagine him
anyway Fez was 16 in season 1 of That
70s Show and was supposed to be around
20 when the show ended Wilmer valderama
was 18 when he first started playing Fez
and around 26 when the show ended even
though Fez was from another country that
the show only specified as a small
village in our reimagination he's still
hanging out with the Wisconsin kids also
not only do we not know where he's from
we also don't know his real name he was
given the nickname Fez because it also
doubles as the phrase foreign exchange
student but Fez was always a girl Chaser
in the show so I imagine he'd be doing
the same thing on the playground ironic
Al though in the show he couldn't really
pull but in this AI version of his
character he's so adorable I'd imagine
he's winning over every girl's heart on
the playground I still imagine Jackie
bullying Kelo all throughout childhood
while he follows her around like a
little puppy dog quick poll though who
thinks Jackie should have ended up with
Fez instead of Kelso munis sure does let
me know what you think in the comments
Jackie was the youngest in the group
around 15 at the start of the show with
milakunis being pretty much the exact
same age as her character I'm sure you
all know the story about how she lied
about her age during the audition if not
the backstory is that they wanted
someone who was at least 18 but Milo
went into the audition anyway even
though she was only 14 the casting
directors pretty much fell in love with
her and they ended up changing the age
of the character the AI generated photo
of Jackie is definitely giving the same
spoiled outspoken vibe that milakunis
portrayed so well throughout the series
so what are your theories about how the
kids of That 70s Show would interact in
grade school do you think Kelo might
have actually been super brainy or that
Eric might stand up for Donna on the
playground the AI possibilities are
endless